so well so let me ask you guys are you
have you been following politics at all
like the the election stuff
yep as much maybe not as much as you you
know but
i think yeah i mean for the most part
we're we're staying up to date but
what's going on well so uh you know the
media said joe biden won
right but donald trump is in court the
certifications hasn't
haven't happened yet and trump is see
trump seems to be firing off
everything in every direction a bunch of
suits i guess
a handful of them got got dismissed
today one of them was significant
by a federal court it was the it was
challenging ballots that came in
after election day even though they were
postmarked before
so that might be a really big deal and
that might uh
that might change things we'll see what
happens that was in pa it wasn't
pennsylvania right so
a couple so um it seems like the
the greatest likelihood right now and
it's like significant is you know joe
biden's on track to be
the next president but we're not there
yet and donald trump
might win well based on everything we've
seen with the media saying joe biden won
in the event that donald trump somehow
pulls this this triple hail mary off
flips the results becomes president what
do you think's gonna happen
unrest man i think we're going to see
just unrest just you know rebel civil
unrest and
uh vacational end your vacation will end
yeah well let me use my vacation but on
a scale of one to ten
with 10 being the worst one being the
the best one being like people handing
out ice cream cones
five being a protest and ten being you
know
war uh war go with a niner
nine go the niner just before war i mean
i really think that
what we're seeing right now like it's
build up on both sides
yeah and so i mean obviously
you know night of we didn't really have
a result but
as of yet we haven't really knock on
wood seen much of anything but i think
all of this is coming to a head and it's
like the calm before the storm
or the eye of the storm it's like the
hurricane hit we saw the riots and now
we're in the middle thinking
everything's fine
the storm's going to move again and then
we're going to get hit by just don't
tell my mom
here okay what about this trump wins
crazy unrest the first night people take
it too far people die then they realize
this is real
and it goes dead for a little while it
depends on who dies i guess
maybe a lot of people maybe a lot of
people i don't think i don't i don't
think so i don't think so if it was a
right-wing individual
who they wouldn't care they would be
like so what
and it was a lefty individual they would
say how dare you they're killing us
and they'll be even more angry but it's
like a family of four and their car gets
burned alive or something
that's like kent state stuff i always
forget no they pepper sprayed kids dude
they didn't kill them
yeah but i don't think no one's gonna
accept responsibility
i don't think it's gonna be caught on
camera before and it's gotta be a
massive shock to the system like
like obvious person waving antifa flag
doing something brutal
on camera and then bragging about it and
yelling like
and then everyone shares and claps for
him maybe the problem is the media
doesn't cover it they won't put it on tv
i i i don't think there's a massive
shock to the system anymore
i don't think anything will shock the
system at this point we saw a guy
get shot by an and that's right dude we
saw a leftist
we saw you know we saw a guy get shot in
denver in the face
happened no one cared i don't think
there is a shock to the system anymore
i think that that's that's the media
that's on the media
because i think that their coverage of
all this has been incredibly
irresponsible
and they just i don't think they care i
mean i think that they're playing
uh a game where they want you know their
side to prevail
and money matter their side is money the
media companies are like
look you got a lot of activists in media
for sure but a lot of these these
these these bosses are like if it bleeds
it leads oh was that guy got shot in the
face
news at 11. you ever seen the movie
nightcrawler that movie is not
so good no i'll watch it oh you gotta
watch it you guys gotta watch it you are
a nightcrawler you are
no no no no wait what is that what you
just don't have a scorecard
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no that was a sociopath
when journalists go out in the middle of
the night and cover crime and you know
you know what though i did chase
helicopters for a little while i was
like where's that
wait a second how do you were what were
you in l.a
i know we're in l.a look they they have
a certain area
right if you're in san bernardino
they're not going to la it's fine
but you know they circle around an area
and you this is what we we whenever i
would be on the ground with my friends
covering unrest
you file helicopters yeah you you're so
we would pull up in la and we'd be like
we were in la we're going to anaheim
where's the riot in anaheim
before the helicopter and then you look
for where the helicopter is and the cops
got lower flying helicopters and you
just go to the helicopter
and then what happened was we did we
pulled into a gas station and there's
everyone this is anaheim everyone's like
it's late at night people are going
crazy
i get out of this suv i close the door
and then this massive
rock probably five pounds goes right
past my head and slams into the ground
and i was like we found it
we're here all right yeah people were
getting shot with those sponge rounds
you know the rubber bullets those are
the worst oh yeah those are the most
painful by far yeah
what are those i didn't get what was it
in the quad man
is it 44 or 40 millimeter 40 40
millimeter could be like 39.
yeah expand on on impact or no no
it's like a like a really hard just like
rubber
i think i have i have one in a box from
france so what do you think
in france i got one what do you think on
a scale of one to ten if biden wins
trump supporters are going to be like
we'll try again in four years
i yeah i mean i i think there may be
more like people are going to start well
you know the new campaign starts today
and yeah you know that's that's probably
what we're going to see
but the far left is not going to be okay
i don't think that they're going to keep
doing it
because also i mean even if biden wins
in philly just a couple weeks ago like
literally on the night of the riots we
were
about 10 miles away from the riots took
place earlier in the night
and we were filming the protesters and
one of the protesters said i like put
the quote
on my twitter was she basically said you
guys are telling me
that the author of the crime bill and
somebody who calls themselves top
cop are your answer to our problems
absolutely not like this this fight is
just starting so
i don't think necessarily like that just
because biden becomes president that all
no of course not i mean blm existed when
obama was president yes
under obama yeah and he made everything
worse and then trump inherited it all
and it's only it only got one what would
be different though is the way that the
press treats
those oh wow they're going to villainize
the protesters
as soon as biden is sworn in
the press is gonna turn around they
already they already are saying that
bernie sanders and warren are locked out
of the biden cabinet
so elizabeth yeah so elizabeth warren
praises joe biden
saying like and the and the progressive
wing saying without him you know
without the progressives biden couldn't
make this victory and then biden's like
get him out of here
yeah bye-bye because bernie's he's an
independent actor
and they can't tell him what to do no
but but but
joe biden is going to throw red meat to
the progressives because too much of the
democratic party's become progressive
but it's going to be to the to the bulk
that are passive
the passive progressives andrew yang
give him like a nice cushy desk job yep
and
and yeah yeah we're going to do a ubi
commission and then you're going to get
a bunch of progressives being like we're
working on it yay and then the more
extreme organizers are going to be
booted out the leadership will be booted
out
and they're just going to try everything
in their power to placate them so it'll
be bad
for everybody but hey you know that's
what they get i i gotta i love it man we
just found out
that um the uh uh us officials were
lying to trump about how many troops we
have in the middle east in syria
yes so that when he was ordering the
withdrawal they gave him
incorrect numbers so he couldn't like
they just lie oh
don't worry trump you've already
withdrawn most of the most of the
soldiers so good go
and then trump's like okay excellent
they were basically defying lawful
orders from the president
we have had four years of government
officials defying
presidential legal orders that would be
imprisonment if i was why aren't they
getting
they should all go to prison yep whoever
whoever like called that shot should be
imprisoned i think
for sure i would say so especially when
it's a president who was elected on a
platform specifically of withdrawing
those troops
and it's like that the people spoke with
their votes
and now we have unelected officials in
our military or in
you know the white house basically
defying that i mean
i think that's more that for me is more
angering than the fact that they're
defying donald trump it's that
there were however many tens of millions
of people who voted for him and they're
saying no
no democracy's not for me they're just
breaking the law
for their own personal gain and for
their own psychotic
beliefs and their arrogance and their
ego and joe biden is now back
he's back maybe and now they're talking
about guess what guess what hillary
clinton cabinet
don't let joe get hot don't let joe get
hot hillary clinton cabinet position
that's what they're saying
it's so funny to me that they're talking
about the will the people in democracy
and voting
and they're having people in these
positions lying to trump about how many
people are overseas
that is such nonsense if you actually
cared about what the people thought
you would care about removing troops
from overseas you would really care
about taking the troops from overseas
you would care about their parents
you care about everyone who's affected
by the wars but they don't
they really really don't which makes me
think that they don't care about the
votes either
but i don't know i mean that's that's
why i mean i think that's a large reason
why trump got elected is because like
basically dc is just on an island and
and everybody is completely removed from
the human suffering and they use
low information voters to
gain power and then now you know i go to
my friends and they're all pro-war all
of a sudden
i mean they're like well trump's bad war
is good and i'm like you think war is
good well it's better than trump okay
i gotta ask awesome who wanted clinton
in the cabinet
it was just something i saw on fox they
were like new conversations about
hillary clinton may be joining the
cabinet it could be bs because everyone
was like
is hillary clinton somehow still going
to become president
dude i vote secretary of state right oh
my god
oh and then the clinton foundation comes
back and then she can fulfill her
contract
all the regular old stuff that we saw
before is coming back and you know
they're just going to protect the thing
that they know
secretary of state and then she can fix
lydia yeah what's going on
how is libya by the way uh slave trade
frack
factionalized civil war air slave trades
yeah yeah
doing well oh thanks refugee crisis
people on boats fleeing
osprey global solutions to get their
arms running contracts
so better better know it better than
trump's america
oh yeah you know the the worst thing
about trump's america was that he was
trying to bring these soldiers
back 2016. i remember he said we're
we're pulling out everywhere that was
one of the things yeah
but yeah but when he first got elected
he didn't he didn't do that
no it was only in the past couple of
years he slowly moved towards it it was
really only this last year he did a
he did a much better job so i had been
paying attention for too long and i
guess i was used to nothing ever being
done
so but no i'm always like i'm always
like well maybe
i i give you know some slack like maybe
it took a little while to get to this
trump really
really was not supposed to win dude the
crazy see it news of all
obama ran on that platform too but obama
obama's foreign policy was completely in
line with american foreign policy
folks i'm going to blow you up with a
drone folks yeah
that's not true these kids got to get
blown up somehow
so i i saw it kids are not going to blow
themselves up yeah that's what i
uh that's that's that's whenever
whenever people post this meme
you know they post something on facebook
like why is our military budget so big
and i was like well you know who's gonna
blow these kids you know what i mean
like someone's gotta drop these drone
bombs
so that's that's it's it's been the us
war machine
obama said he he runs on bringing our
troops back
he gets elected he starts new conflicts
new wars he brings in more troops
ndaa you know signs that the aumf he
just gets worse and worse and worse and
worse and worse what's the aumf
the authorization for use of military
force what would it do so it wasn't him
necessarily
congress re-upped our uh our military
presence
in the middle east basically saying we
are going to sign this thing that says
we should stay and he was like you bet
geez yeah yeah so it just carries on and
you can keep your foreign war folks
you know he said he said that word more
than any other folks yeah yeah any
after after him uh that word skyrocket
look at the stats on google it went up
and now now it's spelled
the ndaa national defense authorization
act is like uh the prom will get
of the i think that's the right word
well so so the patriot acts
no the ndaa is something they do every
year it's the national defense
authorization act
so like the aumf it's like okay here's
this year's budget for what we're gonna
do and then they
say send it to them and i think it was
2012 they added a provision that allowed
for indefinite detention
so under the that that national defense
authorization act
the u.s could essentially rendition
anybody off to an
into an offshore oil rig and then lock
them up without charge or trial and that
was it
same thing lincoln did during the civil
war he suspended habeas corpus
yeah i mean but what they're doing now
seemingly has
i guess it's the war on terror i was
talking to andreas last night it's the
uh suspending habeas corpus is similar
to creating the patriot act
so a few years after they suspended
habeas corpus the next couple presidents
later
uh reinstated it so i think we should
repeal the patriot act
yeah good luck with that did it it was
it was up for like a renewal and i guess
they renewed it right yep yeah but we
could repeal it at any time right
listen when trump tried to pull out
troops out of afghanistan both democrats
and republicans said
no they love it dude he stopped dying
his hair
i don't we haven't jumped in what do you
mean yeah his hair is white again no
you were watching some grain are you
sure dude yeah completely
white this is you know you know you know
the internet thing about the the lighter
you know the thing about the yanny and
laurel thing what about it
you know people it was what kind of
phone did you have
really yes that's chalked it all up to
the phone it was debunked the blue and
yellow dress
it was what kind of phone do you have
it's more than that because people would
be like yeah we looked at it
on the same phone and we just saw
different colors well is it's the same
as the the figurine the ballerina right
some people saw it clockwise some people
saw it counterclockwise
you don't remember that one maybe i just
wanted to see why but but with the
ballerina thing
what's the point though of this of what
analogy like
what do we what are we saying here like
i don't know
yeah different people see different
things when you look at the same thing
yeah i got you ed the mind's
interpreting i mean it looked completely
stark white
oh chad trump's hair because you were
watching a low res grainy internet video
i don't know it was on cnn
no no no it was youtube maybe but it was
youtube it's the same
the same network same channel that i've
been watching have you ever seen a
picture of trump from the ap
they boost the saturation so his face is
bright orange
you ever see you ever noticed this yeah
it's insane yes
trump spray tans yes you can see the
mark on his face
but they really go into photoshop
outline his face and then
blast the orange to make him look like a
clown it's not remembering it they do it
every single day
so i go on and i'm looking at photos of
trump all the time when i'm making
thumbnails and stuff and i'm like
there's the ap and abc again boosting
the saturation on trump's face by 200
percent
then you then you go to like pbs or you
go to
fox and trump's face looks just kind of
pale you know what though
take that example right and then compare
that to uh the way that the press
treated fdr who was a very controversial
and polarizing figure at the time but
the press basically agreed with the
white house that they weren't going to
show that he
was in a wheelchair right yeah and there
were the majority of americans didn't
even know
that he was in a wheelchair yeah and
that was because
the american press agreed that it was
good for the country to
make our leader look strong and i think
now
that kind of like oh we're on this side
or this side but we're all american and
we all want our country to succeed
where the heck is that that that's kind
of interesting to me because
they could do the same thing with trump
they could do the same thing be like he
has his foibles he has his weirdness he
definitely has some weaknesses
but we're going to try to make him look
strong like we're really going to try to
make him look strong but they don't
they did it with fdr they won't do it
with trump however weird he is
however strange he is whatever weird
foibles he has
they won't change how they view him and
this is how they project him to the rest
of the world why do you think that's
actually an issue i don't know why that
is they just hate him
well trump trump wasn't supposed to win
i think like i mentioned this the other
day when i remember when trump
won and i was standing outside of this
building when trump was meeting with
republican leadership
and apparently like they're all mad and
they all hated him trump didn't play
ball
they sat him down said here's our
foreign policy plan here's what we've
been working on here's why we're doing
it and trump went
no i i gotta say i'm looking at the
independent the new york post
uh internet reacts to donald trump's new
gray hair at live press conference
oh okay all right then well there you go
it wasn't a match he stopped dying his
hair he's given up he's he's
done with the crap yeah but that means
he donald trump's was a celebrity before
is he going to retirement he's becoming
real
i don't know i think he's going to do
some real stuff
yeah he's like no more games well you
know what the
there was a real turning point i think
was two two years ago at cpac
when he actually made fun of his bald
spot yeah on the big screen i don't know
if you remember he's like
look at how big my bald spot is like i
thought that was like
i mean a moment where he like showed
some humanity
no no like what's really funny is the
left
they don't know anything about what's
happening outside their bubble
the really good example is when they did
the proud boys hashtag
and they were like take that proud boys
we're making fun of you
and then enrique tario is like here's a
photo of gavin mcinnis making out with
milonopolis
i don't think you know what the proud
boys is oh and by the way
after trump mentioned or after the proud
boys are mentioned in that debate
everybody was looking around for
instances of the proud boys being
violent over the summer and they
couldn't find any
there's nothing shelby talcott and i
we're at outside of the chat yeah
and we filmed the proud boys beat the
crap out of this guy but
so all these people from daily beasts
and stuff like that we're
but that just goes to show how crap so
coverage is but
the point the point is in terms of them
not knowing they think
trump is always comp like always
outraged they're making fun of my hands
that's what they think is happening
so when you watch the family guy episode
where trump's in it his hands are all
small he's really fat he's got an orange
face
trump doesn't care he doesn't when he
tweeted kaffifi he rolled with it and
started doing more
these people have never been to a trump
rally the famous the famous one
the famous bit where he was like these
lights they make me look orange
like he may he he knows he's self-aware
he has a good time he's laughing
and people laugh with them and they
understand it but the left doesn't know
anything
so they're like donald trump is orange
and they're like yeah i know it's really
funny he made that joke
also the degree to which the press going
nuts about him constantly
like the reason why he won that election
is because cnn would not stop talking
there were 17 candidates
but all they talked about was donald
trump and he's like kind of like kanye
in that way he understands that negative
attention is still attention yeah he's
stayed relevant for 40 years because
he's got
five billion dollars with the free press
they said wow free press
whereas all and it was and it's not just
that it's um it's a finite amount of
screen time
so the more trump dominated screen time
the more he pushed everyone out
so cnn was airing these trump speeches
and these trump rallies
now they won't do it you know now
they're like don't don't you know
don't don't show it when trump was doing
the chronovirus press briefings earlier
this year his approval rating was
skyrocketing
and so the immediate were like no no
shut him down shut him down he's lying
he's lying
it's like he's lying he's standing next
to dr fauci
no what they realized was his polling
was improving
because they were covering it so they
stopped covering it saying he was lying
so they won't show the american people
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you